[Music]
either let me see
your arm this one and then go like this
how would you feel if you had
to regrow your penis right here
for four years oh have it on your arm
for four years anything to get my dick
back you get your dick
that's [ __ ] dope i would love that
i will have my dick growing from here oh
my god
from here like a dick unicorn have
because you could be spider-man and
[ __ ] jack it up and go what
you would go like this oh yeah watch
wait wait you
fight crime oh [ __ ]
hi how's it going
they're like is your dick touching my
hand
what do you mean it's a thumb oh dude
you should have a long sleeve on right
so it covers the dick when you're
shaking people's hands
and then right when their hand is in
your hands then you pull the sleeve up
yeah
you could be like you know how big my
dick is look and they'll be like what
yeah i have to [ __ ] weave it through
my body
that's a
you guys are so [ __ ] creative so this
is basically like the the people who
have to like regrow their toe or their
ear on their arm wow
why why the arm okay it's like i got cut
off right and they have to like
maybe the skin's similar get blood from
your body for a while what if
i've touched i know what if you're in
the bathroom though
what if you're in the bathroom and
you're in the urinal peeing
and then you go check this out and
they're like whoa but then you start
peeing for reals
you're just straight confused and [ __ ]
so so you're saying
you're saying the reason why you're
regrowing your penis here
is because it's no longer here oh i
thought you had two for one special
oh yeah yeah it's just like hey do you
want to grow an extra dick by the way i
know you have your own but
you know how to just grow somebody
else's who needs it back joe wants one
of his ear he wants it on his forehead
at his chin
i would i wouldn't mind anywhere i
wonder what that would feel like
to to have the full sensation full
erection and then have like
a dick everywhere and you get [ __ ]
everywhere like how are you oh
i wouldn't be able to leave the house or
jack
no i'm thinking there's multiple
multiple women servicing
each dick oh my god simultaneously
wow joe didn't even hook his own self up
he's working all day this is what you
got when you got like a boner
all right so i'm going to talk to you
guys about malcolm
so malcolm he is 45 years old
and about four years ago he had this
really bad
blood infection affecting his
perineum which is the space between your
your ball sack
and your anus oh that's a nice spot
that's the real word for it
that's a great spot yeah that's a really
wonderful place
so joe's favorite spot that's what it's
called so it he that's when he had the
infection
and apparently he said that he had this
four years which makes me think like
dude why don't you go and like
freaking fix it you get busy sometimes
he this is like the long-term perineum
infection which developed into
sepsis which turned what'd that mean
though
it's just like dying it's like an
infection of your bloodstream and just
parts are just starting to decay how did
he not know that that area was infected
like
did he touch his gucci and be like that
[ __ ] hurt kind of
well it seemed like he knew because
they're he knew that it was like four
years
he had this infection or something
that's why i'm like why didn't you fix
this anyway the point is his fingers
started
his fingers started turning black his
toes started turning but he said that
because
his toes it looked like he just was
wearing black socks only on the toes
oh completely black and did he have to
grow those fingers out he's really busy
what i actually i don't know he didn't
give a [ __ ] about his toes fingers
toes but um well his fingers got better
and all that
and so his penis turned black too so
then one day
he was just walking around his house and
his dick fell off
fell out oh my how does your dick fall
off
because it turned black and it like died
i wonder what it sounded like
you know he well it sounds
to me it sounds dry and dead yeah
like like leaves well it depends if he's
wearing pants like it turns into ashes
on the way down like [ __ ] thanos oh
[ __ ] just [ __ ] how do you have decaying
body parts
i know so wait did he have his balls
still but just his dick filled off yeah
balls are perfectly
the balls finally get sun they're like
yes this falls out of the way
but yeah so they like they're blocked
the dick's always blocking
it with sun like the [ __ ] sun the
whole time yeah he's hogging it all up
all right
sorry well it does now okay so his
oh so this actually happened back in
2014. the reason why i said four years
is because for the last four years he
has been growing his penis
on his forearm that's how long it takes
no so it actually only took two years
he just liked it there he actually did
request
two extra inches which they gave him oh
you got your quack question i requested
two extra inches this is blowing my mind
i know
you want a dick on your arm now not if
it has to turn black dye fall off
in front of me and i have to live with
it for four years on my arm who cares
but i mean it was only two
technically but the reason why it ended
up being four years is because
every time that he was scheduled to go
in to get it removed from his arm and
attached between his legs there were
either like scheduling conflicts
or were like corona you had to get a
ride over there
there was there was this one time where
he was already about to get
wielded into the or like he was already
like everything was
about to happen and then they let them
know oh we actually have a staff
sort a shortage shortage of staff and so
shortage of staff you get i'm sorry
which shaft if they use staff like the
like the wizards
yeah yeah you will not grow
yeah so that's the reason thank you why
it just keeps getting delayed and yes
the most recent reasons
are is because of coronavirus and that's
why he has been getting a nude
take where's his dick wrist
oh why would that's the only thing i
want to see i know why would you say
that's
the only i don't want to see him i don't
care what this is his tinder
yeah oh that's everybody he's moving his
feet no so they have it so yeah he's
still holding on to the base of the dick
it's just that this is where i wonder if
it feels good that's where they detached
it so it could
dangle like an actual like people so he
has a perineum on his [ __ ] forearm
too
yeah huh so i was going under the skin
and they had to cut it so that it could
dangle after
something like oh this is the way it is
wow this is what they did
so this is oh jesus christ oh what they
did is
it says experts take a vein why does it
look like the american flag it does
right it's some american
[ __ ] we need our dicks true so they take
a vein from his body then wrap skin
grafted from his arm around it in a
penis shape and attached it to his arm
then the constructed penis is then
detached from
the forearm which is where malcolm is at
currently
and then knock him in the middle the
step after that is to put it between his
legs
and then also he has to get fitted with
a penile implant
in order for him to get an erection but
he's saying like this whole time
he's like you know what i don't even
need to get hard it sucks
but i'm not even fully tripping because
i already have two kids
so it's all right what about his wife
his wife's like [ __ ] you
i want it he's separated yeah he is
it's it's too easy right now yeah it is
it is so how does the implant work it's
like oh time to have sex hold up
and you have to pump it up so a lot of
people do this actually it's like an air
bed
there's different methods of getting a
penile implant but this specific one
that they're talking about for malcolm
is they have a saline reservoir
inside of his body like like where the
bladder is
so saline is just like salt water so
it's just that's the reservoir
and inside there's like a pump and
release valve
in his testicles and that's where
there's like a little switch
squeezes his testicles no it's like a
little like like a switch thing that
you'll turn on and then so that saline
goes into the penis implant like the
cylinder
and then so the the implant ends up
getting enlarged with the saline
so it's kind of like mimicking so it
does the work for you [ __ ] science
yeah is this like a little chronic is it
so it's like
electronic because you need to pressure
a button in your ball something like
that what happens when you run out of
batteries
no they have it in a wayward it just
forever i don't know
you got to get like remote control and
then like if you accidentally lose your
remote control but like your kid finds
it and it's like
from across the room oh my god his dick
do you think it's like do you think he
has like a wireless charger so whenever
he goes to sleep at night he's
put his balls on the wireless charger
that would be a sight to see
just but yeah plug in the wire i have a
video clip of malcolm in case you guys
want to watch
what kind of video yeah i mean if it's
not going to show me his dick i don't
know if i can
it's not going gonna get hard he's
wearing a hoodie and he's shaking on the
inside
i'm done with that oh actually is he
wearing basketball shirts around his no
he's
basketball basketball shirts yeah yeah i
want to see basketball shorts all right
here i'm gonna
play the video so he his accent's a
little hard
to make out but there is the petals if
you guys can make it out
oh god he's talking about his dick here
we go oh yeah he calls it jimmy by the
way
it's a black no that's fine nothing
trojan black
he's like i'd suck some but my toes were
basically either
just the toes were black and then tears
taze then i wiped the nose because the
end of your limbs or
he's dick in his arm right now yeah he's
actually
keeps slapping it too how did you feel
when your penis fell off
he's also missing like foreign
and what i was going to do is basically
what was left just wrap it up like a
sausage roll
okay outside so that was one of the
options why do you need subtitles for
english
i don't understand
that's all i care about i want his
little friend oh
yeah that's kind of big i'm gonna do
nothing i'm gonna go down the shops with
a t-shirt
with the kids just wrap it up like
you're you're a japanese guy who has
tattoos on oh true
yes yeah i gotta wear like a wetsuit or
something a rash guard just get a kid's
floaty and put it on one arm
he's like going through tsa they're like
frisking him like what is this
is that your penis are you happy to see
me no i really wonder if
so they did say they they mentioned that
they did give them like a vein
and nerve ending well he said sausage
roll
no no the sausage roll was one it was
the option
it was the option before growing it on
his arm so the option that doctors gave
him was
wrap up the little nub that you have and
just deal with that and then he was like
nah let's not do that so then that's how
they ended up referring
him to this dude penal specialist they
actually
yeah they call him something like that
nutrition um
yeah it's a pediatrician but yeah so he
ended up going to this doctor
and then that's when this guy was like
oh let's just grow it on your arm
let's just grow yeah this is great dig
on your arm no because he's actually
done this before
how did he find that out yeah doctor the
doctor
out of all the third penis they call
them the penis master
it's not my first time hey what kind of
chemical or whatever do you
like drop to make that [ __ ] part of
your body going like
i'm gonna grow a dick here no it's not i
explained it to you remember they grab
the skin they shape it into a penis
shape and then it like the the tissue
ends up healing
while living on your body but does it go
programmed to be dick so does it not
have all the characteristics of
addiction like the head and everything
it's just
a log no i mean they showed it to you
yeah i know that's like that's a very
drawing
but i don't know if they like really did
that right because if you just wrap up
skin how do you get the head part yeah i
think what they're saying is
they get it like anatomically
but the penis the penis has a mind of
its own
it's the mind in that ball of flesh oh
no that's what i'm wondering maybe like
a
a plastician afterwards that you know
because it really dresses up the head
mushrooms it out a little bit
carves a nice urethra but even if it's
flaccid it can feel good and that's what
makes it grow
but if his dick is there it's just a
physical
dick but it doesn't feel like a dick
that's what i want to know because they
did mention that they did give him
nerves
so i'm like can you feel it then yeah
like it's just another arm yeah the arm
nerves or the penis nerves
i hope it feels good is that why it's
called the forearm
foreskin oh my god foreplay yes foreskin
oh [ __ ]
you